and maybe we leave it alone but I was
just chuckling at this [ __ ] specific
tik-tok because my man in the back in
his [ __ ] like football dad outfit
yeah I was chuckling this is like should
I do you even need sound for this now
you know it's yeah so if you just
listening this is a couple boys one of
which i think is too old to be in this
damn oh hype house buddy on the right
okay there only is like 22 or 23 em [ __ ]
and everyone else is on the far right
yeah they're twins so it's two guys I'm
pretty sure are they yeah I think so
whatever my it's my understanding the
dudes in like his mid-20s and the high
house is full of fifteen-year-old he's
in that [ __ ] doing this stuff doing
body rolls and pump in the air now that
being said ondrea's lopez i know he just
might have just dissed you a little bit
but if you want to do a dance to broke
[ __ ] yeah yeah go for it go for it dude
like you know we're not gonna stop you
in fact I think you're scared yeah I
think you walked to it I think you're
scared you're afraid of doing a dance I
I didn't really bring this up I'm just
chuckling in my man in his in his
football dad outfit because look he
should be playing sports he got the body
movement of a athlete yeah this move is
really funny yeah this move yeah like
four four-four homies to sit around back
okay and then we're gonna do yeah do the
do the do the finger butterfly to the to
the waist and then hit and then
immediately is a body roll right after
and then what we're gonna do is we're
gonna walk towards the camera and smirk
because you know you can tell but he
likes to dance but it's just like it's
just his body's not yeah it's not like
doing what he wants it to do and that in
the end this ite t-shirt you know and
his his coach and coach Kyle outfit that
[ __ ] is like it's just not this is not
the kid that walks through the back -
yeah that's how you know that's a you
know the hype house
people are checked out oh yeah oh yeah
yeah they're doing the body to do this
all day today is [ __ ] this is their
sixth hour of doing this yeah
you girls are do behind the camera like
that like the coach in the [ __ ]
Netflix cheer show he's like yeah it's
five six seven eight two people we
removed the last two counts the body
roll goes after the finger butterfly
Jesus [ __ ]
so you guys aren't listening to me why
do they start with five it's only
explain that [ __ ] to me
yeah why isn't it one two three four
maybe it's like the ideas like you're
gonna so you start on one yeah but you
could just go one two three four one two
three four you could do that you could
do that or you know two three four five
six seven eight nine ten eleven twelve
twelve and a half
thirteen one just keep going yeah the
[ __ ] yeah we should finish every podcast
episode like this where we go alright
[Laughter]
I'll walk up the frame to turn it off
yeah there it is there it is there it is
hidden that [ __ ] I would just let this
[ __ ] loop we give it on them loops I
don't know whiners liners let's just do
them right now to camera yo what up
honey meet gang welcome back you're
listening to Apple music it's gotta be
on the phone Kyle's here too alright
let's just wrap it up thanks for
listening to the sleep apnea episode
guys we are doing the bonus episode
tomorrow yeah yeah and if you're if you
were body rolling along with us then we
appreciate you yeah if your body rolling
along in the comments you know feel free
to throw us a few jazz fingers and shut
up the coach Kyle
yeah Celtic I love it I did not
see that guy you didn't know look at
that little man I was saying that a dude
on the right looks like the e boy
version of the villain from the kind of
look at this kid is Rex Ryan's nephew
trying to do choreo you know who I'm
talking about
the fit is [ __ ] up already you don't
saying like he can't hit it
I feel bad he got the you got the body
role of a linebacker look at my god
there's one more time let it rip
let it rip search this guy Crispin
Crispin Glover oh boy well that's been
Glover yeah sounds like a porn name
oh yeah yeah yeah but it yeah my picture
of him with like parted hair yeah that
one that one that I sent you this joint
yeah yeah he does he does got that
Crispin Glover look he really does man
the boy version of that what Crispin
Glover
you